-Wh-a-a-a-a-at?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hackney Diamonds" is out now.
The new Rolling Stones
album is out now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he is on our show tonight.
Last night,
I was very, very lucky.
I got invited to the --
to a secret show, actually.
I went to the album --
It was the album --
What do they call it?
-Release.
-A release party.
I go, "Great. I'll go to see
the album release party to see,
you know, Mick and Ronnie
and Keith are there."
I go, "Great."
I go, "Are they playing?"
They go, "No, no, no, no, no.
No, it's just
an album release party."
"Okay, cool."
I go, "Well, that's fine.
I'll just go."
And then I saw you,
and you go -- you're D.J.'ing.
-Yeah.
-And you're there, so I go,
"Oh, cool. That'll be fun.
I'll see Quest.
It'll be fun to go out there."
I go in there.
It's a tiny club.
Tiny.
Where was it? Racket.
-Racket.
-On 16th Street, I remember.
It's a beautiful club
but small.
But there's instruments
on stage.
-Oh.
-Ooh.
-There's a drum set.
There's guitars.
There's a microphone.
I go, "Uh-oh. I think
something's gonna go down."
All of a sudden,
the lights go out.
Questlove's
not D.J.'ing anymore.
He's sitting where I'm sitting.
I go, "Dude, what's happening?"
You're like, "Oh, yeah,
it's about to go down."
They come out,
and it's almost like
♪ Shadow, shadow ♪
I was like, "What?"
It was unbelievable.
I was -- honestly, I think --
I'm not kidding.
I don't want to complain.
I think I was too close.
-Yeah.
-Do you think we were too close?
-That'll never happen
in our lifetime again.
-I was too close to the Stones.
-Wow.
-I think it was
a little distracting.
-Like, how close?
-Well, like,
say I'm here, right?
This is me.
-Right.
-And he's like --
And he's like, "Go away,
go away, go away.
[ Gibberish ]
"Go, go! Stop! Go!
Move out of the way!"
Like, he couldn't --
I was ruining his mojo.
Mick was out
doing his thing, and...
And I was just like --
I was just, like,
sitting, like...
I was getting --
I was getting a lap dance
from Mick Jagger.
I don't do that.
-Yeah.
-I don't do that.
But it happened last night.
It was unbelievable.
And they came out, and they just
showed everybody how you do it,
which is like, no tricks,
no computers, no anything.
"Give me a guitar,
give me a microphone.
I'm gonna show you
how to rock out."
And they destroyed.
They were so great.
And at the end, they finished,
and they -- they leave.
And, you know, I don't know
if there's such a thing
as encores anymore.
Not really, right?
You kind of know
they're coming out for one more.
They have to.
Right?
The lights turn on,
and you go -- we go home.
Back in the day,
you have to go, "One more..."
They don't do that anymore.
I'm fine with that.
So I'm playing the game.
I go, "Yeah,"
but I can --
I can see the lights aren't on,
so they're gonna come out
for one more.
Not only do they come out
for one more,
Lady Gaga comes out
with The Rolling Stones.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, all-timer performance.
-Yes.
All-timer performance.
-Yeah.
-Everybody --
Keith was on fire.
Literally.
Someone lit him on fire.
He was like -- he just played --
He was awesome.
Ronnie Wood and Gaga
just went for it.
Rock 'n' roll.
It was unbelievable.
All the new songs
they played, it's great.
Anyways, "Hackney Diamonds"
is out officially today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
On our show.
He is one of the greatest
guitarists of all time
in one of the greatest
bands of all time,
The Rolling Stones.
New album, "Hackney Diamonds,"
is out now.
He is here with us tonight.
Keith Richards is on the show
tonight, so that'll be fun.
That'll be cool to see, Keith.
That'll be great.
But we'll get to Keith...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Not now. Later.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
-That was a walk-by.
-Not now.
-Yeah.
-He will be on the show,
but not -- not yet.
[ Laughter ]
How cool is that dude
right there?
He just --
you know, just walk out.
[ Applause ]
He doesn't care.
He's Keith Richards.
He does what he wants.